rends compte que tu la connais que
depuis un mois ça fait trois jours que
je connais si ta mère je suis enceinte
oui justement tu appelles coquine
ouais merci ben tu ne regardes la
nouvelle maman j'emmène à bas les deux
semaines comme ça tu prends ton petit
appartement parce que tu ferais bien
d'un montant ça va c'est encore l'autre
là la paire email
je me souviens j'avais j'avais à peu
près tournage il avait rencontré mon
calabraise francesca recycleurs need et
surtout elle avec deux fois mon âge elle
m'a tout appris
on passait nos journées à faire l'amour
c'était crevant c'était bon ça je te
passe les détails mais moi j'avais
jamais autant pris mon pied
alors j'étais persuadé que ça allait
durer toute la vie reprend parce que moi
j'ai été comblé physiquement spirituel
c'était spirituellement
oui mais un jour je sais pas ce qui
m'arrive je sens une sorte une sorte de
lassitude ras-le-bol toi je alors bon
moi je m'inquiète évidemment je prends
rendez vous chez le toubib et là
j'arrive au cabinet je tombe sur une
petite assistance stagiaires de prune à
la pommade une toile de maître
à peine à la fermer la porte on se jette
là sur l'autre et larusso miettes
laissées à béziers tu peux pas savoir je
la [ __ ] retourne des grands noms
mais c'est un peu comme si je j'avais
fait mes gammes dans le classique et que
je me lançais dans le moderne
tu comprends ce que je veux dire